Simon come we're happy to lie better
care to but consistent dear friends hope
you guys are doing well if your
non-muslim welcome to my channel
but many videos you can watch all of
them and find the truth about Islam in
the proper way by jerusalem's you know
not about anyone else you know if you
have a problem of your lungs
you don't go to about the butcher to
find out what's wrong with your lungs
you know you go to a doctor you know so
this is basic knowledge but sadly people
go to individuals actually Robinson
whose love is an extremist cause for
violence just start Isis dude Isis call
for violence and maybe use nine Muslims
just the way he himself is naive and
silly and full of accusations so he
targets individuals out there who share
the same mentality as him to attack
innocent people like ourselves so who
ends up suffering innocent people
innocent non-muslims innocent Muslims
innocent seeds innocent Christians
whatever it may be because of such
individuals with hatred in their heart a
preacher's extremist now as you guys
know he made an accusation about me that
I was insinuating I was involved in a
Manchester task yesterday
I made a video reporting it to the
police and we the police came today and
I've reported it this is the paper I've
reported it to the police
inshallah inshallah and ensure they're
gonna Kurt Imel T it's one meter cool I
wanna take this to court because you are
putting my life in danger and you're
putting my family's life in danger and
you you are something that should know
better you yourself get death threats
yeah you yourself get difference about
your family etc by ignorant individuals
and you are the same person that's
causing other people to send me death
threats
you know that's why I seat you you wants
the same as those extreme groups what
I'm gonna do this we're gonna watch your
video that you did yesterday so let's
watch this in shot so I put that out and
yesterday you do a video and rebel media
I'm looking forward to meet you guys too
please let's get in contact yeah it's
easy to get a camera from the camera in
rubbish
me in person and show me a single place
in the whole of Islamic history the
Quran and hadith that orders the killing
of innocent people
I dare and challenge you I'm looking
forward to meeting you guys
my life is in danger
firstly Tommy Tommy why are you driving
I think I think you'll be good for you
on the road yes please forgive me
how dare I just slip that what what a
grave sin I'm so sorry please forgive me
Tommy you know funny enough funnily
enough when I run the police
I thought they don't know this guy yet
because everyone knows what kind of a
person you are
I said do you know Tom Robinson and the
ladies I know she won't know me she
specifically said I don't know and I was
quite surprised I thought like she does
know she didn't know you but besides the
point what child is saying hey she of
course they won't know me hidden
yeah it's childish behavior anyways yes
[Music]
amazing come back to me no one likes a
snitch stop that now this is really
important here nobody likes a snitch so
you know what you did is wrong
and the heat is on you now you
insinuated the economy if you had a lead
our I don't we got that from yeah where
do you hide anything from here okay you
are more in common with those jihadis
than me yeah you insinuated first
committee Hadi yeah
secondly you insinuate and thirdly
you're coming to telling me snitching
yeah
snitching what the hell are you what are
you talking about of course I will
snitch any kind of terrorist activity I
will snitch whoever it may be if I know
somebody's gonna cause harm to innocent
people yet just the way you are gonna
you because of you you could cause harm
to my life on my family's life because
you're making people think that I I was
involved and I told people not to go
that's disgusting
it's a low blow you know it's fake news
yeah it's his faith rubbish news you're
brainwashing naive people out there just
the way Isis does language individual
innocent people get hurt because of you
innocent Muslims out they get hurt now
me if I know a Muslim which whoever he
is if he is going to I know clearly
going to cause harm to innocent people I
will go to the police I will go to the
authorities because it is forbidden in
Islam to cause harm to innocent people
it is absolutely forbidden and let alone
in this town we have that we believe in
covenants yes we live in this country
you have to abide by the laws of this
country because we have a covenant to
betray that covenant by going and
killing innocent people is the biggest
treachery the Prophet Mohammed peace of
home said is it's the biggest treachery
yet because you are living under this it
will reside in here you come John see
it's the biggest treachery against this
government to kill innocent individuals
so you're coming to me and saying you're
a snitch held right on a snitch you are
causing people to attack Allah's our
snitch
any other person if I had any attack any
think about the attacks that for example
Joe Cox is murder
the Farah in the video who killed Joe
cops yeah if I knew I'm going to the
police
I'm not gonna be like hey no if I knew
the Manchus
attach that guys doing I will go to the
first is I will try to get that guy and
pin him down myself before he does
anything and you're calling me a snitch
I'm happy to be a snitch and you know
very well you if are you telling me that
if you saw somebody doing that attack or
know somebody you're looking to snitch
were you gonna say hey my street cred is
more important innocent people's lives
you know like a 14 year old man you know
are you mad who kids and some people
some people coming to me that ah
you're a your dares how he snitch I was
like wow this just goes to show you how
shallow some people's mindsets are yeah
well you're you're 40 or man you've got
children they said don't snitch we're
not living by some street cred we live
like slum I don't care of something turn
everyone rough you get me we don't care
about all that Street years well knows
we don't live that life yes we're trying
to be Muslims here
my religion teaches me that if anyone's
look like for example gonna cause a huh
crowd manage I have to we have a
translation so hashtag hashtag I'm a
proud snitch but if you publicly
apologize and retract that statement I
would you know this police thing I'll
take it back yeah because I'm gonna drop
to your level if you do that if you
don't mate I'm taking mr. core all the
way to cool what you did yes I did
I told Muslims to not go to a concert
it's my belief I live in Stanford you
their Jewishness Jewish quality did you
say to Muslim oh don't go to the concert
in Manchester no this is free so cool
so why is why are you insinuating yes
that he said all don't go to the concert
in Manchester trying to try to make up
lies to spread hatred yes or any
preacher known only that they the Jewish
community there yeah they don't they
don't integrate that's the thing that's
the thievius some of them I talked to
good in the videos I don't I probably
they have their own schools
yeah they wouldn't send their children
to the concert yeah cuz it's against
their faith yeah I did the same I said
Muslim you should go to such concerts
alcohol yeah there's alcohol there's
music there's all these stuff that we
believe that you should bro it killing
innocent pins as if you've killed all of
humanity exactly and this was everywhere
we are against terrorism no matter where
is Iraq millions of people were killed
yeah my ministry by America and the UK
I'm not saying keep Tony Blair yeah we
are against any kind of killing of
innocent people
it's not forbids it that's why I
challenge you that's why you don't you
know that if you if you come to me face
to face on camera you are going to have
to be quiet you have to shut your mouth
you know why because nobody in Estanza
teach the killing of innocent people
none zero absolutely zero police time so
okay okay let's get right on romance and
you see there's it then what this guy's
got desperate yeah yeah he's complained
yes and he's not to use a specific work
but you've gone moaning to police or
what you got morning to some people
oh I'm doing district so long English
Channel fool I'm getting there's a gas
tank why are you wasting Channel full
time why are you wasting wasting time
yeah it's rubbish you know of course I
am you're you're putting my life in
danger what am I gonna do just oh no of
course I am only count is you seriously
the only con is you you're there you're
just talking for the same hours when you
spend rebel media that which I'm looking
for I'm looking forward to me in you
know I'm just looking for that if you
guys are really truthful in what you say
meet us brother wish you people is how
you sound like I wish you could watch
yourself you know you know when you just
have to push it out like
you know I did why keep repeating this
obvious I quote like 101 and connected
me to Muslims going around out in a
second look Joe Cox is murder the way he
talks it's like every happens it's only
Muslims every single what what about all
the Muslims dying in Syria as a result
Isis what about our little Isis one
second one second what you to Isis Isis
what did Isis seem to you me yes the
hours in one of Isis's me personally did
I was in one of Isis's videos yeah where
they're saying all of these people that
were showing you their blood is halal
meaning who knew them do you know what
that means you know what that means that
means Isis are saying that's him he
should be killed
Isis is our enemy let alone yours they
want to kill us first
yeah they weren't because they think
well you know these liberal Muslim etc
even over over they send and if this to
us okay now guys why wanna see it's very
simple and very clear yeah I'm not gonna
long this out too much
you shut up caused me to go Joe might as
well he's Tommy if you retract yeah
retract and say look he's not a jihadi
and make it clear that I know his shape
or form I did not tell people too
because of that yeah I'm happy I'm fine
without you get it because you are
putting my life in danger because you're
putting idiots out there who's gonna
believe your rubbish just the way they
believe you get certain Muslims believe
in the rubbish of Isis and carrying out
tremendous this is these disgusting acts
yeah just the way your brain works in
the murder the murder of Joe Cox who
went and killed her in daylight
butchered her yes you are to blame
so I'm asking you kind of take you down
yeah
just clarify just one clarification from
your side Jay you don't want to do that
no problem for the report yeah I'm gonna
pull you up I will carry this one till
we go to court I will carry this on till
we go to court and you pay for it and I
know you've been in trouble with the
police you don't want to get this in
your record and I'm not gonna be an
absolute idiot and and I could that
could easily say you know what I'm gonna
follow this fruit I'm not gonna do that
yeah I'm not gonna drop to your level
because my religion teaches me better so
I'm just asking you kindly to do that
and secondly please meet us let's me
have a discussion let's pool yeah what's
your problem this time let's discuss it
all yeah that's all we're asking you to
do you don't want to do that no problem
me
well not Quilliam we're not Quilliam
we're not prevent we're not mi5 well not
more once our yeah we're not all of
these people we're not washed yes yeah
we are all for docs Muslims yes you're
in a meet time and place we're not seen
let's have a one-on-one no it's not done
for intellectual discussion you're
bringing Clint I will bring you I
challenge you and anyone any place in
the Quran or the hadith that the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him or anyone in
Islam killed innocent people that islam
teaches the stuff challenge anybody
anytime i speaker's corner every Sunday
I'll come wherever you want that's about
it guys hope you enjoyed it share this
brothers and sisters share this to show
that our true what Islam really teaches
and show other people how hatred the
hate these people are sharing out there
just like a sister's family can work
like that care to please please share
this